when it is revealed that violence replaces
peaceful negotiations and that intimidation and
coercion replaced the ballot box that congress's
them clearly obligated and duty-bound to review
existing laws and determine the need for remedial
legislation in the Scranton area I think it'll be
disposed of some union officials engaged in
bullying tactics and made use of violence and
terror tactics to impose their will not only on
certain segments of the business community but
also on members of their own Union Robert Malloy
called me one morning says Paul and we're meeting
down at the lunchroom we've got some trouble with
a milk concern out of scramming so he says we're
gonna go out and give a guy a bad time so we met
at the lunchroom must have been about 15 or 20 of
us all together four or five got needs to pee
in one car four or five in another car we all
had instructions to get around to each each part
of the town and some of the boys include myself
the car I was in we went up into the country so
we come intact with one of the drivers and we
asked him about organizing so at the beginning
he didn't want to organize he says he didn't
want no part of the Union so we had to gallon can
filled of kerosene woulda's which spot Malloy gave
us and with the instructions to pour it over
the milk the eggs and the butter in the truck
and when we want to do that the man says he'll
join he'll join that was in that and he did he